oh non
[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous pour cette nouvelle édition
spéciale est tout d'abord donc le
silence d'une europe en deuil
à midi des centaines de millions
d'européens se sont tus pendant trois
minutes
un fait sans précédent dans l'histoire
de l'union un moment de recueillement
observé partout en france en mémoire des
victimes de l'elysée à matignon en
passant par les entreprises et les
écoles
les français ont exprimé leur douleur et
leur solidarité dans un silence
impressionnant
m
merci l'activité peut reprendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toute l'europe s'est donc figés durant
trois minutes sur tout le vieux
continent les cloches des églises ont
sonné le glas toute une population
encore sous le choc des effroyables
images diffusées depuis mardi
de londres à bucarest de stockholm à
rome l'europe entière en passant par
bruxelles a exprimé sa solidarité avec
l'amérique
le bilan risque bien sûr encore de
s'alourdir mais trois jours après la
plus grave attaque terroriste de
l'histoire
au moins cinq mille personnes sont
mortes ou portées disparues dans les
décombres du pentagone et des tours
jumelles de manhattan dans une ambiance
cauchemardesque les secouristes
poursuivent inlassablement le
recherchent un travail de plus en plus
difficile
lorenzo
essais libres 2
about
anyone else
et les musées de saintes
[Musique]
entre 200 et 350 pompiers auraient péri
dans l'effondrement des twin towers
souvent soldats du feu de fer en fils
les pompiers new yorkais n'ont jamais
connu telle hécatombe et pourtant malgré
la pluie torrentielle qui s'est abattue
sur manhattan
les relèves se succèdent les travaux
continuent descours garde espoir
bon ça va refroidir la couche supérieure
des gravats sans l'appui les gravats
fonctionne comme un couvercle et le feu
continue de couver
si vous connaissez les feux de forêt que
nous combattons régulièrement l'effet
est à peu près le même lot qui éteint le
feu l'eau qui nourrit aussi d'éventuels
survivants
certains pourraient s'être réfugiés dans
des tunnels de service qui relie entre
les six bâtiments du tweet sainte mais
de survivants sortis des décombres trois
jours après la catastrophe
il n'y en a eu que neuf parmi eux ces
cinq pompiers dont le sauvetage hier à
regonfler le moral des troupes aux
espoirs
ces hommes sont tombés dans une crevasse
le matin même 48 après le drame
rudolph giuliani le maire de new york se
veut malgré tout rassurant il y a
toujours un fort espoir de retrouver des
survivants voulons bien bonnes chances
de trouver des gens et de les sauver
entzheim un message officiel qu
attendait sans doute les familles après
trois jours d'un silence angoissée elle
est ce enfin exploser leur douleur
personne ne peut comprendre ce qui s'est
passé ici personne
il était dans la tour numéro 2 82e étage
nous étions en train de parler quand il
a vu l'avion arriver et je n'ai plus de
ses nouvelles depuis jeudi ce n'était
pas il faut que nous le retrouverons
c'est nous seuls enfants trouvent un
corps je juge a trouvé quelque chose je
veux savoir même s'il est morte au clair
assurer uniquement dans les twin towers
on reste sans nouvelles de près de 5000
personnes ce soir le maire de new york
aurait commandé six mille sacs
mortuaires l'amérique compte également
c'est mort à washington au pentagone le
siège du ministère de la défense les
recherches se poursuivent
soixante dix corps ont été désormais
retirés des décombres 126 personnes sont
toujours portées disparues a ajouté ou
64 victimes à bord de l'avion détourné
cela porte le bilan environ 200 morts
pour la capitale des états unis de leur
côté les enquêteurs du fbi qui continue
d'explorer des milliers de piste pour
tenter d'identifier les auteurs et les
commanditaires
plus de 7000 agents fédéraux sont sur le
pied de guerre une gigantesque enquête
qui dépasse largement les frontières
américaines
puisqu'aujourd'hui des arrestations ont
eu lieu en allemagne et même aux
philippines aux états unis où la
psychose de nouveaux attentats grandi
plusieurs suspects ont été interpellés
dans les aéroports new yorkais
emmanuel gagner
dans un pays à cran les fausses alertes
se multiplient hier plusieurs
arrestations dans les aéroports new
yorkais
ce jeune homme et d'autres pour et était
sur le point de commettre un attentat
information erronée relayé par la rumeur
dans ce climat électrique l'information
progresse le fbi a il sait désormais que
les kamikazes étaient au nombre de 19 7
étaient des pilotes confirmés
certains auraient été formés aux états
unis dans des écoles de pilotage privé
sur la côte est ou en floride
sept instructeurs américains et écoeuré
sans le savoir il a contribué à
l'entraînement de plusieurs kamikazes
si nous avons transmis notre expertise
le fichier de cette école de pilotage le
prouve
mohammed atta l'un des terroristes
présumés passer par là sur sa
nationalité les informations divergent
originaire des émirats arabes unis selon
certains égyptiens pour d'autres aux
états unis at est accompagné d'un
deuxième homme
marwan al shehhi un emirati avant leur
mission meurtrière sur le sol américain
les deux hommes ont séjourné hambourg
inscrit comme étudiant dans cette
université technique atct heihachi
aurait vécu dans cet immeuble ont
compagnie d'un troisième terroriste
la police allemande a perquisitionné
plusieurs appartements et arrêté deux
personnes
relâché faute de preuves
pas de suspect mais une certitude
l'allemagne a servi de base logistique
il y a aussi d'autres traces des
terroristes et pas seulement ici à
hambourg mais aussi dans d'autres lieux
où plusieurs kamikazes ont séjourné une
enquête qui rebondit aux philippines
le 8 septembre trois hommes originaires
de man ont été arrêtés soupçonnés de
films et l'ambassade américaine soupçons
infondés
ils ont été relâchés trois jours après
l'un d'eux aurait pris part aux
attentats américain amani aujourd'hui un
homme a été arrêté
il s'agirait de mohamed bichari un
pilote de ligne d'une compagnie
saoudienne présenté comme le frère d'un
des kamikazes
pas de réponse les policiers devront
vérifier l'information
et puis il ya ce message dallaire un
communiqué du département d'état
on voyait à toutes les ambassades il est
daté du 7 septembre soit quatre jours
avant la catastrophe
on peut y lire d'après une information
que nous avons reçue en mai 2001 les
citoyens américains pourraient être la
cible d'une menace terroriste de la part
de groupes extrémistes liés à
l'organisation d'oussama ben laden
suivent ensuite une série de
recommandations de prudence des
recommandations que les autorités
américaines n'ont pas appliqué sur un
territoire
george bush est attendu ce soir à new
york où le président américain doit se
rendre sur les lieux de la tragédie
ce sera la première visite à manhattan
de george bush depuis mardi le président
des états unis qui en cette journée de
deuil national a assisté vous le voyez à
washington à un office religieux en
hommage aux milliers de victimes et en
direct de new york nous retrouvons l'un
de nos envoyés spéciaux jean marc pitte
il est 13h30 à new york
george bush doit bientôt arriver mais
certains américains estiment que cette
visite est un petit peu trop tardive
oui bien sûr quand on demande aux new
yorkais quand george bush aurait dû
venir leur réponse est claire il aurait
dû venir le jour même de la catastrophe
il l'attendait il le souhaitait il n'est
pas venu mais ce retard était si facile
m'en excuser un chauffeur de taxi nous a
expliqué que george bush avait beaucoup
de travail qu'il comprenait ce retard en
fait les américains sont aujourd'hui
dans un autre état d'esprit
ils sont dans l'état d'esprit de
l'alliance sacrée de l'union sacrée et
tout le monde est derrière george bush
tous les hommes politiques tout le
peuple et on le voit à travers des
démonstrations de patriotisme quand on
se promène dans les rues de new york
on voit beaucoup plus de bannière
étoilée qu'il ya quelques mois ou
quelques jours les bannières étoilées
sont sur les voitures de police sur les
voitures privées
même sur les vélos sur des fenêtres les
gens ici ont besoin d'affirmer leur
patriotisme on voit hoggy également se
soucie de d'union dans la messe à
laquelle assistaient george bush les
anciens présidents américains étaient à
côté de lui
toutes les chaînes de télévision de
nombreuses chaînes de télévision
américaines retransmettaient cette messe
et il y avait également les
représentants de toutes les religions
également un représentant de l'islam qui
a commencé qui a qui est acquis à une
bonne place dans cette messe merci jean
marc pitte en direct de new york chaque
jour de nouvelles images et de nouveaux
témoignages des rescapés nous
parviennent des états unis après le
premier impact dans la tour du world
trade center la plupart des salariés qui
se trouvaient dans leurs bureaux n'ont
en fait pas du tout réaliser le drame
qui se jouait mais une heure plus tard
l'immeuble s'effondre et des minutes de
doute d'angoise et d'en faire claire
perdrix
la journée commence
banal a priori 11 septembre
8h45 à manhattan
soudain le choc
[Applaudissements]
un premier avion faire [ __ ] le world
trade center le plus célèbre building du
monde est en feu à l'intérieur des
milliers de personnes sont déjà au
travail
elle ne réalise pas encore l'ampleur du
drame ces photos dévoilées pour la
première fois sont prises quelques
minutes seulement après le premier crash
le photographe sortira indemne
les employés se dirige dans le calme
vers les étages inférieurs
mais les couloirs sont étroits et les
pompiers arrivent l'angoissent monte par
les fenêtres certains appellent déjà au
secours ils sont prises au piège
ceux qui s'en sortiront sont des
miraculés j'ai vu les débris les
morceaux de l'avion et plus les gens ils
tombaient par les fenêtres et puis je me
souviens quand on est descendu je
regardais dans l'escalier les issues de
secours étaient bloquées on regardait
partout et puis on a essayé d'avancer
les gens disaient des choses comme des
prières
oui des prières la 22e compagnie new
york accélérait ce sont les hommes les
plus courageux que j'ai vu de toute ma
vie allait il montait les escaliers je
me souviens encore de leurs visages ils
avaient tous les yeux bleus je me
souviens de ça aucun d'eux n'avait l'air
effrayé
aucun d'eux une femme et au 79e étage
quelques minutes après le crash elle
appelle sa famille
tout autour d'elle été condamné c'est ce
qu'a dit ma mère les portes les
toilettes
tout était en feu mais la dernière chose
qu'elle a dit à ma soeur c'est qu'elle
allait s'en sortir et qu'elle nous
appelle raid et qu'elle serait de 100 on
attend encore qu'elle nous rappelle
beaucoup n'auront pas eu le temps
d'échapper à l'enfer 18 minutes après le
premier crash
un autre avion percute la deuxième tour
une heure plus tard il ne restera des
deux bâtiments que des gravats et de la
poussière
le world trade center s'est effondré sur
plusieurs milliers de victimes parmi la
population américaine s'est toujours
l'union sacrée le pays fait bloc
derrière son président georges bush qui
a d'ailleurs qualifié ces attentes at
deux premières guerres du 21e siècle
dans leur majorité les américains sont
favorables à une riposte armée le sénat
à l'unanimité lui a autorisé le
président à recourir à la force
et comment 91 pour la guerre du golfe et
bien près de 50000 réservistes vont être
mobilisés christelle meyrals
je m'engage solennellement à soutenir et
défendre la constitution des états unis
contre tous les est mort ces jeunes font
désormais partie de l'armée américaine
ils ont prêté serment hier à los angeles
ils sont encore au lycée
mais après le choc des attentats leur
décision est prise je veux m'engager et
faire quelque chose pour aider la patrie
empêcher que cela n'arrive une nouvelle
fois je suis daltonien alors je ne peux
pas me battre et tuer ceux qui ont fait
ça mais je peux faire un travail
administratif quelque chose comme ça
c'est ce que je veux faire et les
nouvelles recrues se comptent déjà par
centaines à los angeles comme partout
aux états unis de nombreux jeunes
veulent rejoindre les forces armées nous
pouvons tous être fiers de ce
patriotisme qui s'accroît que nous
voyons à travers la nation c est cette
vague de patriotisme submerge tout le
pays
le congrès a appelé les américains à
déployer le drapeau en signe de
solidarité
en deux jours des centaines des milliers
de drapeaux ont été vendus qu'ils sont
arborés partout sur les maisons les bus
les voitures
face au drame qui touche l'amérique en
plein coeur fini les batailles
politiques
bill clinton appelle les américains à
faire bloc autour du président bush
je ne suis pas président je suis un
citoyen mais je vais soutenir le
président et j'appelle chaque américain
à faire pareil nous devons être prêts à
payer le prix de cette bataille face à
un terrible adversaire
nous devons tous rester soudés et le
pays se prépare à une riposte harnais le
président george bush a autorisé le
pentagone à faire appel à 50000
réservistes sans attendre trente cinq
mille d'entre eux ont été rappelés tour
entré en guerre contre le terrorisme
les avions kamikazes ont surpris le
monde entier pourtant depuis plusieurs
années l'utilisation d'appareils civils
transformé en véritable bond
avait été envisagée par les terroristes
des actions en redoutable que craignait
d'ailleurs il ya déjà trente ans les
israëliens patrick esther clément
weill-raynal 1972 le président libyen
kadhafi il vient de créer sa compagnie
aérienne
les équipages sont d'anciens pilotes
d'air france aux commandes ce jour là le
commandant hanotaux le boeing 727 qui
vient d'egypte s'est garé au dessus du
désert du sinaï les israéliens pensent
qu'il a été détourné leurs chasseurs
abattent l'appareil 111 morts des
passagers égyptiens pour la plupart
aujourd'hui
igal carbone ex-colonel des
renseignements militaires israéliens qui
avait supervisé l'en quête raconte et
explique pourquoi l'armée de l'air avait
décidé d'abattre l'appareil pendant 10
minutes
les avions de chasse israéliens ont
tenté de rentrer en contact radio avec
lui il n'a pas répondu
ils se sont mis à côté de l'avion à la
hauteur du cockpit
on a fait signe de la main au pilote
qu'il fallait qu'ils se posent il n'a
pas répondu
nous avons eu très peur qu'il arrive
jusqu à beersheva ou tel aviv et qu'il
se crashe sur la ville nous n'avions pas
le choix
alors nous l'avons abattu au dessus du
sinaï le premier vol suicide qui a
véritablement failli s'écraser sur une
ville paris c'est l'airbus d'air france
détourné à alger le 26 décembre 94 par
miracle
l'airbus qui n'avait pas assez de
kérosène pour aller jusqu'à la capitale
a dû se poser à marseille où le gign est
intervenu
si l'avion avait continué son vol il
aurait dû être abattu lui aussi préfère
ne pas être à la place de chef d'état
qui aurait elle décidé que finalement en
droit battre n'a rien mais ce le cas
échéant nous cette décision doit être
prise passionna le choix entre la mort
de quelques dizaines de personnes dont
cent personnes puis classe donc on n'a
pas tellement choix l'année suivante en
95 à manille aux philippines
la police avait déjà arrêté un homme
adoul mourad impliqué dans le premier
attentat contre le world trade center
dans les mémoires de son ordinateur
la police avait trouvé la preuve que
l'homme était pilote professionnel
mon sentiment c'est que ben laden
recrutait des pilotes déjà depuis 1995
et que mourad avait été recruté et
d'autres suicides qu'il était prêt à
réaliser une mission qu'amicale avec un
avion et il faut savoir que tous ces
pilotes
recruté par ben laden était en outre
formé à utilisation des explosifs à
manie décidément plaque tournante de
nombreux commandos suicides dans les
couloirs du nba correspondant d'interpol
l'avis de recherche de ben laden était
placardée depuis longtemps les
philippins avaient même découvert un
projet terrifiant baptisé bojinka
prévoyant de faire exploser un avion de
ligne à destination des états unis
en fait patrick esther il se confirme
que parmi les kamikazes qui ont ce
qu'ils se sont crashés marque il y avait
plusieurs pilotes très expérimentés
oui c'est ce que confirme d'ailleurs ce
soir le fbi y aille qui affirme que sur
les dix neuf pilotes de l'art de l'air
et bien sept au minimum étaient des
pilotes confirmés alors on regarde en
d'ailleurs les enregistrements radars
des trajectoires de ces avions détournés
les experts avaient déjà compris bien
sûr qu'il fallait que les pilotes soient
capables de naviguer puisqu'ils ont
piloté pendant plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres en faisant descendre les
avions d'un niveau qui était aux
environs de 10 mm avec une chute rapide
si vous voulez jusqu'à 350 m donc des
experts quand même du maniement en
l'occurrence il paraissait relativement
peu possible que soldés des pilotes d
ulm si vous voulez et pu réaliser des
percussions dans les tours de de cette
précision et on voit bien que le second
appareil s'est incliné très fortement
or les experts en regardant bien les
images ont pu voir que les avions
n'avaient pas les volets sortis
c'est à dire que au moment où ils ont
percuté ils ont percuté à grande vitesse
est là encore pour pouvoir réaliser un
virage de cette importance à grande
vitesse après une descente rapide
il fallait un expert alors ses pilotes
ont reçu une formation en floride mais
est ce que cette formation était
suffisante néanmoins pour mener de
telles actions et bien effectivement
louis on peut commencer à douter du fait
que simplement des pilotes de piper club
soit capable de faire ça alors quand on
regarde un petit peu si vous voulez les
informations qui viennent d'autre part
on s'aperçoit qu'un quotidien arabe
édité à londres
à préciser que des commandos auraient
été entraînés en afghanistan sur des
avions de la compagnie et ariane alors
la compagnie argana c'est la compagnie
afghane qui a été interdite de vol par
l'onu et dont les avions ont été
condamnés à des vols intérieurs
alors sur une base aérienne qui se
trouvait à l'ouest de kaboul
on sait que au minimum 14 de fanatiques
ont été entraînés au pilotage de boeing
727 dévoyé 527 d'ailleurs en très
mauvais état
deux avaient été revendus d'occasion par
air france il y à déjà très longtemps on
sait que sept au minimum de ces
fanatiques parlait parfaitement
l'anglais on sait qu'ils avaient pour
certains des passeports européens et que
les 14 hommes ont quitté donc
l'afghanistan ian peut-être était-il aux
commandes des appareils qui sont crashés
merci patrick esther ce n'est pas encore
officiel mais tout porte à croire ce
soir que le commandant massoud des morts
plusieurs sources confirment d'ailleurs
ce décès le chef militaire de
l'opposition afghane avait été très
grièvement blessé par l'explosion d'une
caméra piégés dimanche dernier et ce
n'était pas un acte isolé chez le lien
est désormais établi entre cet attentat
et ceux commis donc 48 heures plus tard
à new york et à washington
l'insaisissable oussama ben laden
recherché depuis des années par tous les
services secrets a donc vu s'effondrer
les symboles d'une amérique qu'il a
déclaré la guerre à la tête d'une
véritable international terroriste ben
laden dispose d'une immense fortune et
de milliers de fidèles un réseau
implanté dont de très nombreux pays et
qui s'était étendue au fil de l'histoire
joël hasard quelque part en afghanistan
les hommes de main de ben laden
capturé par les partisans du commandant
massoud afghan arabes asiatiques
une légion de fanatiques formés pour la
guerre sainte
[Musique]
l'afghanistan sera une base pour nous
pour que nos réseaux agissent dans le
monde entier dans tout l'occident en
afrique du nord et dans d'autres pays
comme les philippines
c'est la guerre froide qui a contribué à
forger des générations de terroristes
islamistes afghans pakistanais algérien
utilisées par la cia pour déloger
l'occupant soviétique d'afghanistan les
états unis souffle sur les slams pour
contrer l'influencé de moscou qui tient
les mosquées tient le pays avec les
guerres du proche orient le sous
développement
le fanatisme religieux se répand les
régimes arabes modérés accusée d'être
inféodée à l'occident dispose avec un
intégrisme virulent la guerre du golfe
va fanatisés un certain nombre de
mouvements islamistes
les alliés de ben laden accuse les
régime saoudien d'avoir profané la terre
sainte du prophète en accueillant les
troupes américaines le terrorisme se
répand comme une traînée de poudre ou du
moyen-orient maghreb en asie 19 morts
385 blessés américain dans l'explosion
d'un camion-citerne devant une base à
dhahran en egypte la jamaa islamiya
multiplient les attentats comme à louxor
60 morts dans l'attaqué d'un car de
touristes ici aussi c'est tout ça m'a
ben laden qui finance l'opération
le milliardaire terroriste n'a pas de
mal à recruter les partisans chez les
moudjahidine où les fedayin car la paix
marque le pas au proche orient la
bataille pour jérusalem entre israéliens
et palestiniens galvanise la djihad la
guerre sainte relance le terrorisme et
la violence du cycle attentat
représailles contamine toute la région
paul balta bonsoir soir avait été
longtemps journaliste au monde vous
venez de publier ce livre idées reçues
sur l'islam est-ce que l'on peut parler
comme certains l'affirment ces jours ci
d'une nouvelle guerre de civilisation
c'est notamment la thèse du célèbre
politologue américain à samuel
huntington
vous êtes d'accord vous avec cette
notion de guerre de culture
non parce que à mon avis il y a tout de
même entre en tout cas par exemple en
méditerranée malgré le conflit israélo
arabe
nous avons énormément de points en
commun même avec le monde
ab le monde arabo musulman cela étant il
est incontestable que les islamistes et
les partisans de ben laden veulent faire
de leurs actions une guerre contre
l'occident et une guerre mais aussi à la
limite contre les musulmans pacifiques
et je crois qu'il faut se défendre de
cela attention à l'amalgamé c'est ce que
vous dites ce soir absolument et je
dirais que autant je suis solidaire des
souffrances du peuple américain
autant pour avoir couvert depuis 79 la
révolution iranienne et les événements
de la région
je ne suis pas d'accord et je ne suis
pas solidaire des erreurs commises par
leurs gouvernants
justement c il faut remonter à la
révolution iranienne à la guerre du
golfe pour comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
ce que reproche à l'occident et en
particulier aux états unis les pays qui
peuvent soutenir ces réseaux terroristes
via écoutez c'est tout de même les
etats-unis qui ont soutenu sièges chaque
le général qui a introduit la charia au
pakistan ce sont eux qui ont donné le
feu vert au retour de khomeiny en iran
et ce sont eux qui ont tout de même
soutenu les talibans et ben laden en
libye au début et c'est la cia qui a
formé les la guérilla des taliban est ce
qu'on appelle internationale islamiste
donc des tas de jeunes qui venaient
d'algérie d'arabie saoudite l'egypte et
ses terrains qu'on appelle les afghans
entre guillemets et qui ont été formés
par eux et on retrouve certains d'entre
eux à la tête du groupe islamique armé
en algérie ce soir les états unis et
l'otan réfléchissent à l'éventualité
d'une riposte sur qui concrètement les
américains et leurs alliés peuvent
s'appuyer pour mener ses actions sur le
pakistan sur l'arabie saoudite qui
pourtant joue le double jeu et bien
c'est là qu'il ya une ambiguïté parce
qu'après tout les saoudiens ont tout de
même financier il faut bien le dire un
certain nombre de mouvements islamistes
ils sont parmi les très rares pays à
avoir reconnu les talibans et à des
soutenir donc il ya là toute une
ambiguïté il n'en demeure pas moins que
la plupart des pays arabes
même s'ils se sentent frustrés par
rapport aux états unis ne peuvent pas
être ce qui s'est passé ce n'est
absolument pas coranique ça ne
correspond pas du tout à l'enseignement
de l'islam
cela étant il faut voir aussi que depuis
quelques années une grande rancoeur
s'accumulent dans le monde arabe
si vous voulez le problème palestinien
n'est toujours pas réglé malgré les
résolutions de l'onu
et puis une fois pas oublier aussi qu en
irak il y a les bombardements et qu' ils
ont fait d'après l'organisation mondiale
de la santé près d'un million et demi de
morts dont cinq cent mille enfants de
moins de cinq ans merci paul balta
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
une situation internationale qui
inquiète le monde politique français cet
après midi à l'assemblée s'est tenue une
réunion exceptionnelle des commissions
et des affaires étrangères et de la
défense
avec pour thème unique donc évidemment
les attentats et la question des
représailles
les députés sont solidaires des états
unis mais l'organisation de la riposte
en revanche ne fait pas l'unanimité
reportage michel lemaire l'un des
parlementaires français unanime pour
rendre hommage aux victimes des
attentats
mais après le temps de l'émotion pointe
le temps de l'action et c'est sur ce
terrain qu apparaissent plus que des
nuances la riposte contre les
terroristes est nécessaire il faut aussi
associer dit-on sur tous les bancs oui
mais pas dans n'importe quelle condition
ajoute-t-on aussitôt dans les rangs de
la gauche pour parce qu'on fait cible
et il faut que la france tout en excès
n'assurant sa solidarité totale avec les
américains garde sa libre appréciation
comme l'union européenne
ne cédons ni à la simplification ni à la
malgache
l'islam ne peut et ne doit être confondu
avec le terrorisme mais le rpr tout
conte fée n'est pas si éloigné de cette
position même s'il fait référence à un
président de la république qui notait
hier que la france au moment de frapper
serait totalement solidaire des
américains il faut tout faire pour
éviter que ce soit un choc de
civilisations et il ne faut pas
confondre les fanatiques terroriste avec
les groupes religieux ou nationaux dont
ils sont issus ne globalise ont pas
cette lutte contre le terrorisme en la
transformant en une lutte contre des
peuples tout entier c'est finalement du
côté des libéraux consent la plus forte
volonté de coller sans réserve majeure à
l'allié américain sur le thème la
solidarité du coeur doit clairement
déboucher sur une solidarité de l'action
rock à l'heure actuelle ce serait une
erreur politique de manifester vis-à-vis
des etats-unis et des mesures à prendre
une attitude de restriction ou de
contester on va donc dans les semaines à
venir retrouver pour l'essentiel les
clivages apparu lors de l'intervention
au kosovo alors nous venons d'entendre
les réactions françaises françois paul
et mathis est ce que les européens sont
vraiment prêts à suivre les etats-unis
non c'est éventuelle riposte
les européens sont prêts pour une
riposte dure mais ils sont prêts pour
une riposte adaptée il considère qu' on
n'est pas dans le cadre de la guerre du
golfe et donc le temps à elle même
considéré qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de
faire des préparations de plans
d'invasion par exemple de l'afghanistan
les européens d'ailleurs font valoir
qu'une guerre disproportionné avec des
ennemis qui ne sont pas encore donné
risque de ramener d'une certaine manière
le terrorisme à l'intérieur même de
l'europe donc face à cela il faut une
réponse adaptée une réponse nouvelle et
originale les européens font en
particulier valoir que les nuits qui est
à chasser n'est pas seulement dans les
camps d'entraînement
dennis temps mais il est aussi dans les
banlieues de londres de new york de
paris c'est donc là aussi qu'il faut le
pourchasser d'où l'idée d'une opération
coordonnée à la fois sur le terrain à
l'extérieur là où effectivement il y à
des terroristes qui s'entraîne mais
aussi dans les capitales européennes
pour éradiquer le terrorisme et à ce
propos on peut considérer que mardi les
européens ont peut être enfin compris
qu'il était temps d'imaginer une police
ans comme françois paul et mathis merci
après trois jours d'arrêt total le
trafic aérien international vers les
états unis a repris un très lent retour
à la normale à l'aéroport de roissy par
exemple trois vols transatlantiques ont
enfin décoller aujourd'hui pour le plus
grand soulagement des touristes
américains qui ont vécu le drame loin de
chez eux le reportage de didier brignon
et jean-pierre heckmann
files d'attentes interminables devant le
comptoir de delta airlines un vol pour
attentats les premiers passagers à
embarquer pour les états unis seuls les
compagnies aériennes américaines ont pu
faire partir quelques avions à
destination d'atlanta ou encore houston
les trois aéroports de new york a reste
toujours fermé du coup air france a dû
annuler ses 28 vols
les traits tirés des centaines de
passagers tentent quand même leur chance
j'essaie de trouver un vol retour pour
les états unis mais le trafic aérien est
glauque avec l'état on ne peut toujours
pas partir avec air france donc je vais
essayer avec delta airlines on essaye de
rentrer mais mais c'est dur le premier
avion du par on le prend mais les petits
soucis vont s'effacer devant le
recueillement dans l'après midi air
france annonce des mesures de sécurité
renforcées
désormais des agents en civil est
spécialement entraînés accompagneront
les vols sensibles le contrôle de
l'accès à bord sera accentuée et tous
les couteaux interdit dans les cabines
un message fort à destination des
passagers alors que l'inquiétude n'a
jamais été aussi grande et malgré
l'annulation de nombreuses
manifestations ce week end la
superproduction d'aïda de verdi est
maintenue ce soir au stade de france à
saint-denis 78 mille spectateurs sont
attendus de nombreux policiers et
gendarmes sont sur place dans le cadre
bien sûr du plan vigipirate l'enceinte
du stade de france a été entièrement
fouillé pour éviter tout risque
d'attentât
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de l'avoir suivi si le dernier
journal le soir 3 aux alentours de 22
heures 25
présenté par jean sébastien fernandez
très bonne soirée et à demain